[Music]
hello again the gays welcome to my
garden party fantasy straight people you
of course welcome to tag along to
provided your emotionally damaged hi hey
how are you cringe let's talk about it
the word cringe has taken over my
vocabulary lately it just pops into my
head all the time like when I randomly
remember that month back in 2013 when
all of my facebook posts were just
lyrics to Ke$ha songs rewritten in
iambic pentameter why
what audience was that for who is this
inconceivable person I used to be cringe
mega cringe I think I say this word like
50 times a day
cringe cringe cringe and I'm not the
only one Google Trends shows that in the
u.s. search interest in the word cringe
has dramatically increased over the last
decade peaking in 2016 and remaining
pretty constant ever since and if you
look at worldwide trends search interest
in cringe I said an all-time high the
month I'm making this video so what is
cringe well let's start with some
examples there is a recent threat on ask
reddit titled what things really make
you cringe and here's some of the most
up voted responses the time I was
talking too loud at a wedding when I
wasn't supposed to and everyone at the
wedding turned around to see what
[ __ ] wouldn't shut up recordings of
my own voice when I remember that I did
that I do have a boyfriend he just goes
to another school thing early teen me so
many cringe stuff I did I hope all my
old friends have forgotten about me this
happened about two years ago I ordered
some pizza hutt online and when it was
delivered the lady handed me the pizza
boxes I said thanks and she told me my
shirt was inside-out I said oh and then
she hands me the receipt to sign and
leave a tip and I spent 30 seconds
trying to get the pen to work she looks
at the pad and says you have to click
the pen I said oh and then she reaches
to get the receipt and tells me the
pizza smells good then I said you'd see
oh and then I closed the door and killed
myself all of these responses illustrate
exactly what writer Melissa Dahl says in
her book cringe-worthy a theory of
awkwardness
according to Dahl the moments that make
us cringe are when were yanked out of
our own perspective and we can suddenly
see ourselves from somebody else's point
of view she quotes the anthropologist
Edmund
who in the 60s did a study of the bee
ami tribe in New Guinea where he showed
them mirror video and photographic
images of themselves for the first time
and described the results they were
paralyzed after their first startled
response covering their mouths and
ducking their heads they stood
transfixed staring at their images only
their stomach muscles betraying great
tension so basically they cringed it
themselves
maybe self-awareness always begins with
cringing like pretty much everyone seems
to hate the sound of their voice when
they hear a recording for the first time
I guess because it sounds different from
the way you hear it resonating in your
head so when you hear the recording you
realize oh god that's how other people
hear me all the time and you're suddenly
aware of this clash between the way you
appear to yourself and the way you
appear to other people that's when you
cringe the feeling doll describes as the
intense visceral reaction produced by an
awkward moment
an unpleasant kind of self recognition
where you suddenly see yourself through
someone else's eyes it's a forced moment
of self-awareness and it usually makes
you cognizant of the disappointing fact
that you aren't measuring up to your own
self-concept when you're talking too
loud at a wedding and suddenly Erwin
turns around to see what [ __ ]
wouldn't shut up you suddenly realize
how you look to them because we've all
at some point turned around to see what
[ __ ] wouldn't shut up
but this time you're the [ __ ] cringe
often it's the violation of an implicit
social norm that makes us cringe there's
no law of state or even of etiquette
that tells you exactly how loud you're
supposed to speak at a wedding it's
something you have to intuit based on
context how loud are other people
speaking is the ceremony about to begin
and we're all supposed to be quiet now
according to youtuber Vsauce Michael
here the function of awkwardness is that
it's sans
social dynamics by smoothing out what
even etiquette doesn't rule on cringe is
the electric shock the emotional
punishment for being awkward it enforces
the limits of socially acceptable
behavior by wounding the ego and
memories of your crunchy moments are
often just as painful as the moments
themselves 10 years later you'll be
trying to fall asleep and for no reason
at all your brain will decide to remind
you of that time you were talking too
loud at the wedding and of this stupid
thing you were saying when everyone
turned around to stare at you
and you'll cringe all over I got that's
why remembering your teenagers is so
painful because you look back and you
realize damn I was the [ __ ]
for like seven consecutive years can I
just hire a hitman to kill everyone who
remembers me before I don't know
November no all the examples we've
considered so far involve self cringe
but usually when we talk about cringe on
the internet we're talking about
cringing at other people popular
subreddits like our slash cringe cringe
pics and cringe topia hosts videos and
images of people behaving in cringy ways
for instance a maternity photo that
looks like a hostage crisis grim moments
of lamentation and cuckold Rhee and Mitt
Romney attempting to communicate during
his first encounter with black people
watching that makes me feel like my soul
is on fire it makes me want to crawl out
of my body and escape into another
dimension I think some people feel
cringe more intensely than others for me
it's uncomfortable to the point where I
will reflexively pause a video like that
because I just can't stand it in other
words it's like watching my own YouTube
videos which sweaty if you put that [ __ ]
on I will leave the room so why is it
that cringing at other people hurts in
the same way as cringing at yourself
well one theory is that cringing at
other people is simply vicarious
embarrassment or secondhand
embarrassment basically it's a form of
empathy when you cringe at someone
you're feeling the embarrassment that
they're feeling just as if if you watch
someone fall down the stairs
you might win so pathetically with their
pain but there's a problem with the
vicarious embarrassment theory of cringe
or at least a complication which is that
in the purest examples of cringe the
person doing the cringy thing isn't
feeling embarrassed
in fact often they're super confident
and it's actually their lack of self
awareness about their embarrassing
behavior
that makes you cringe like when a woman
posts a ridiculously over face tune to
picture of herself as if anyone's gonna
believe she looks like that or when a
man thinks he looks like a badass tough
guy when he actually looks like an
embarrassing dingus so in the internet
sense of the word cringe is not just if
I carries embarrassment someone tripping
and falling onstage is embarrassing and
I do feel embarrassed for her but she
knows it's embarrassing and she feels
embarrassed because you feel bad that I
fell and that's really embarrassing but
thank you nothing about this is cringe
maybe to her it's self cringe maybe she
looks back on it and it's still
embarrassing but I don't cringe at her
maybe there's a difference between
cringing at someone and cringing with
them
when someone falls on stage I cringe
with her in the sense that I feel
vicarious embarrassment my feelings
mirror what she's feeling
but when I'm cringing at someone I'm
feeling something very different to what
they're feeling I'm cringing at captain
badass overhere because he doesn't have
the decency to cringe on himself
another example is bad American Idol
auditions which are quintessential
cringe content people try out for
American Idol because they think they're
good enough singers to compete in a
national competition so they're
effectively revealing their own
delusions when they show up and sing
like this it's not just that he's
terrible that makes it cringe most of us
are bad singers right when people sing
happy birthday at a party usually
they're singing in three different keys
at no particular tempo but that's not
cringe because the point of singing
happy birthday is not to sound amazing
bad American Idol auditions are cringe
because of the contestants misplaced
confidence who you as good as in your
opinion the lead singer from Queen it's
the hubris of thinking you sound like
Freddie Mercury when in fact you sounds
like a wounded street dog
I admit that watching red I'm actually
not in very much pain when I'm cringing
at him I laugh at his ludicrous
performance just like the judges do and
because he's so cocky and because he
doesn't show signs of embarrassment
himself there's a part of me that
actually kind of enjoys his failure
there's almost a sense of Karma a sense
that because of his tragic hubris he
deserves the humiliation he's bringing
upon himself and my sense that he
deserves it suppresses my compassionate
response and helps remove any guilt I
might otherwise have about taking
pleasure in someone's humiliation
contrast this with another Idol cringe
contestant Misha who's there with her
mom and they both seem like such
sweethearts I do believe in her a talent
that was very beautiful and yeah she's
delusional about her singing talent but
I'm rooting for her and when she
embarrasses herself
I feel no joy only deep and agonizing
cringe don't you wish your girlfriend
was hot like me yikes
my differing reactions to red and Misha
track a distinction that dole makes
between compassionate cringe and
contemptuous cringe compassionate cringe
involves an emotional identification
with the person you're cringing ah even
if they aren't embarrassed themselves in
the cringe-worthy moment you still feel
the embarrassment they would feel or
perhaps ought to feel if they were aware
of how other people were perceiving them
contemptuous cringe on the other hand
involves an emotional distancing from
the person you're cringing on just like
with compassionate cringe you perceive
that the person is embarrassing
themselves but instead of feeling
embarrassment on their behalf you feel
annoyance and disgust
octa and maybe even a little shot in
photo so these are actually two very
different emotional responses vicarious
embarrassment versus contempt we call
both feelings cringe not because there's
similar feelings but because their
responses to the same type of situation
people lacking self-awareness
embarrassing themselves without
realizing it now embarrassment and can
seem at face value like pretty
unpleasant feelings so why are we so
fascinated by content that makes us feel
this way why do these cringe subreddits
have more than a million members
why are cringe compilations and cringe
reaction videos so popular on YouTube
why does so much comedy feature cringy
situations well I think the answer to
that question depends on whether we're
cringing compassionately are
contemptuously when I read that ask
reddit thread where all the people share
their cringe stories I cringe
compassionately that is I feel vicarious
embarrassment for them and with that
compassion comes a sense of solidarity
and camaraderie with them I recognize
myself in them and I'm reassured to hear
that other people are just as awkward
and embarrassing as I am I'm not the
only one who cringes up my past or in
videos of myself I'm not the only one
who sometimes says you to when the
person says the pizza smells good when
we collectively laugh at these
situations we're bonding over our shared
human frailty we're recognizing that we
all say the wrong things sometimes that
we've all arrogantly argued for an
opinion only to later educate ourselves
and realize how ignorant and wrong we
were that we've all tried to present
ourselves as cool and likable as
beautiful and talented badass only to
totally miss the mark and completely
embarrass ourselves and laughing at our
shared absurdity or insecurity or
ridiculous pretenses it makes us feel
less alone now this is all of course
assuming that we're cringing
compassionately but I would argue that
most cringe content on the Internet does
not encourage compassion and that's kind
of an uncomfortable thought because we
like to think of ourselves as morally
evolved this is the 21st century right
Hillary's and freak shows and public
floggings these are barbaric practices
from the Dark Ages right surely no one
on the internet would ever entertain
themselves by humiliating people right
we've got maniacs
we've got whackadoo we've got skit suits
fatties and spurs come seize sexual
deviants on display that's right folks
we've got cackling perverts and every
denomination come see the panty sniffer
he'll stop at nothing to indulge his
twisted cravings come see the skeleton
girl she hasn't had a bite in 30 days
that's right we've got real live lesbian
and I'll be your master of ceremonies
half man half woman all freaked okay
we've heard enough heartwarming
gibberish welcome to the dark side of
crime watch here on youtube.com we have
a cringe culture and by that I mean
there's whole channels making content
that centers the experience of cringing
and there's a huge audience that seeks
out cringe content including content the
creator didn't intend to be crammed much
I first started paying attention to this
back in 2016 which was the heyday of the
feminist cringe compilation for SJW
cringe compilation remember those this
is ancient history by YouTube standards
but in 2016 the word cringe was most
associated with a youtuber called
leafyishere his videos followed the
format of a cringe reaction video which
means he would play someone else's
content then pause it to Rampton
voiceover about how cringe it is no I'll
make up with some sweatpants oh my god
it's so [ __ ] bad he looks like he's
gender-fluid he looks like a [ __ ]
lesbian this format of cringe reaction
videos was very influential and it was
picked up by a rational herd of a
skeptical beasts and free-thinking
tuxedo what even is this thing it must
be one of the 76 genders
I didn't realize [ __ ] was a gender
sorry my dudes you were on the cringe
side of history obviously there was a
political angle to SJW cringe videos the
logical antelope isn't inviting you to
foster a shared sense of humanity by
recognizing your own weakness in the
embarrassment of screeching feminists no
this isn't
invitation to contempt here's a youtube
video titled fat acceptance cringe
compilation you'd expect from the title
that it would be a video of fat
acceptance activists behaving in cringy
ways but it isn't it's literally just a
compilation of fat people doing things
this is just a clip of a fat woman
swimming is this cringe what is cringe
about it earlier we defined cringe as
either vicarious embarrassment or
contempt for someone who lacks awareness
about the way others are perceiving them
but in this video of a swimming of fat
woman there's no context so we don't
know anything about her mental state and
we certainly don't know what that she's
self-aware about how she's being
perceived if there is an interview where
she talks about how she looks like a
supermodel or if she tried to Photoshop
herself to look a good size for okay
maybe that would be cringe but that's
not what's going on in this clip she's
just existing in water what cringe
are we being invited to feel over this
presumably something along the lines of
you fat people gross it's literally just
disgust right
disgust and contempt for a type of
person a type of body
here's another cringe compilation this
one titled gender fluid non-binary
cringe and we're watching a young
teenager discuss their plans to start
blogging about their gender fluid
identity honestly it's kind of
terrifying because you know like a
gender-fluid people just aren't accepted
yeah apparently not and judging from the
fact that I'm currently watching this in
a cringe compilation it's seamless that
the person in this video was dead-on
about how people would perceive them but
despite that self-awareness we're being
invited to cringe because I guess being
gender fluid like being fat is cringe in
and of itself
now the pennant in me wants to oppose
this use of cringe
this is not real cringe I want to say
cringe has to involve a clash between
self perception and perception by others
but this usage of cringe as a mere
synonym for contempt is so widespread
but there's really no point in objecting
to it if you look at the banner image of
cringe topia one of the sleazier cringe
subreddits you can pick out a new taco
with a waifu body pillow a furry
bronies a fedora tipper these are
subcultures associated with nerdiest
social outcasts there are types of
people who are widely ridiculed online
I'd like to share with you a list that I
put together of groups that are often
considered to be cringe bronies furries
otaku weaves in cells neckbeards fedora
tippers gamers tic toc teams not like
other girls girls fanfic writers speed
poets sjw's feminists magaz trans people
non-binary people transgenders queer a
fab you call a li players autistic
people thought people the mentally ill
and the mentally disabled now i'm
searching for some thread that all these
groups have in common and a handful of
themes do jump out deviancy whether
physical mental social or sexual a
combination of passionate sincerity and
amateurism the perceived tendency to
lack emotional composure obsessive
interests in unconventional hobbies low
social status it's pretty easy to wind
up in the cringe category these days if
you add up all the groups on this list I
bet it includes most of the people
watching this video it includes me three
or four times I'm of course a fedora
tipping queer a fab you clearly playing
tic toc team can we just accept that
we're all a bit cringe and try to be
like compassionate or whatever [ __ ] no
the internet will not abide any of that
kumbaya [ __ ]
oh no this is social reject battle
royale clearly contemptuous cringing is
rewarding to people in some way and I
want to explore what the rewards might
be let's start by looking at the rule of
cringe in internet politics where
manufacturing contempt is a powerful
strategy at the height of YouTube anti
feminism 2016 or so you couldn't escape
clips of this woman known as big red a
Toronto resident who showed up at a
men's rights event and read off a list
of feminist theses while swearing
profusely part of patriarchy I don't
know if you're noticing a theme
patriarchy I'm reading
made mister entitled mr. Eagle
patriarchy [ __ ] me
she's one of these people who generates
nameable phrases at an amazing rate I
actually think she's hilarious and
iconic but I have unconventional tastes
Anastasia anyway this video appeared in
callous cringe compilations reaction
videos or remixes and even anti-feminist
video essays often big read was framed
as like Z feminist the mascot of
feminism is sort of metonymic stand-in
for all feminists which is highly
dishonest considering she's not even a
high profile act of history thinker she
was literally some random woman on the
streets of Toronto but because of this
amusing 12-minute video it was insisted
upon that we all take a stand on this
random woman who we were told
exemplified feminism in its purest form
I call this strategy mascot ization the
construction of a strawman nemesis what
you do is you select a cringe-worthy
person and you appoint them the mascot
of an opposing political team it's very
simple but very effective and it's best
paired with Mema fication that's when
you take a single moment in a person's
life you freeze it and you declare that
that moment fully represents a person
then through mascot ization you declare
that this meme affined person represents
an entire group or movement other
right-wing memes from this era include
this protester NEMA fight his aides and
Skrillex
and this protester who was Mima fide has
trickly puffs the two of them symbolized
the wretchedness of bethe new male
cockle tree and the hysteria of social
justice cry bullies respectively I guess
the ultimate Mima fight mascot was Anita
sarkeesian about whom hundreds of hours
of salty gamer ramblings have been
uploaded sometimes indeed it was
caricatured as cringe as like this fake
gamer girl this pleb tier cosmo throwing
a pathetic tantrum at real gamers but
other times it was almost a super
villainous caricature this sort of dark
devouring mother archetype threatening
to confiscate your videogames and engulf
you and her eunuch abyss now it's
obvious why caricature in your political
enemies as supervillainess it
though it comes at the risk of
backfiring by making your opponent seem
a little bit too powerful a little too
badass but the subtler strategy of
symbolizing your political enemies not
with an evil but with a cringe-worthy
mascot works because it connects with a
wide audience in an intense emotional
way most people have a primal terror of
becoming the target of public ridicule
and if someone has been made a
laughingstock it's much safer to take
the side of the people doing the
laughing than it is to risk being
laughed at yourself to be cringe is not
to be in on the joke because people
crave acceptance and dread rejection I
think one reason we're so fascinated by
cringe content is that our brains want
us to learn how to avoid being laughed
at when we see a mob of people whether
in person or online laughing at someone
in ridiculing them we register an
emotional memory of it as a warning
don't act like that or people will laugh
at you this is a powerful tool for
anyone who wants to control human
behavior it's why public humiliation has
in many societies been a punishment for
criminals you see a person in the stocks
in the pillory at the whipping post you
see the mob jeering and throwing rotten
vegetables and it sends a powerful
message don't do whatever that guy did I
don't think the Internet has yet reached
self-consciousness about the fact that
the fear of public humiliation rules us
like as the 17th century there's no
judge sentencing people to a day in the
stocks but instead there's teenage
youtubers making cringe reaction videos
there's ex-boyfriends revenge posting
their girlfriends nudes this vigilante
Twitter mobs harassing and shaming just
about anyone for alleged breaches of
woke Ness public humiliation is a
powerful force and it's usually it's not
a good force but there are some rare
exceptions back in the gamergate era
gamergate itself of course being a study
in public humiliation slut-shaming on a
massive scale
YouTube commentary was increasingly
dominated by anti feminism as far as
leftist content there was the Young
Turks and there is a network of besieged
feminists of loggers who were constantly
mobbed in her
what I see is one of the turning points
and shifting the atmosphere from the pro
gamergate days to the left tube world of
today was a handful of videos uploaded
by then obscure youtuber Harry Brewers
in which he mocked a misogynist
pseudo-intellectual called davis oriini
come on Davis we have to know stop
lecturing me about ethics we have to get
out of here and can you please stop
trying to start a forest fire in his
YouTube videos Davis would pontificate
about the wickedness of women while
posing in front of a toy skull and
taking microscopic sips from a glass of
whiskey men of the West women in our
culture have become the most decadent
[ __ ] since the fall of Rome and so in
discussing [ __ ] versus [ __ ] I would
start with the premise that all women
are [ __ ]
hairy's videos ridiculing Davis
attracted
of views and a fairly positive response
even from a mostly male gamer audience
who were overwhelmingly anti-feminist at
the time why did these videos work with
this audience where so many others
didn't well I think it's because harry
didn't moralistically call out divas for
being problematic or misogynistic
instead he simply drew attention to the
fact that Davis is a cringe-worthy
buffoon and Davis was a perfect target
because he truly is cringe in the
traditional sense
he had no self awareness about the fact
that pretty much everyone saw through
his absurd posturing as a badass tough
guy by day profoundly dark philosopher
by night we exist in a world with
feminized legislation I spoken to men
and boys who have told me that Harry's
videos inspired the beginning of a
feminist awakening of them not just
because they cringed at Davis arena but
also because they recognized a little
bit of Davis in themselves and they
cringed at that too recognising part of
yourself in a cringe-worthy person
induces self scrimmage which can
motivate you to change your behavior
your beliefs or even your own
self-concept and it helps that Davis is
a perfect instance of a recognizable
stock character on the Internet namely
the fedora tipper basically a man who
poses as a gallant crusader for
traditional masculinity but who's
basically just a pasty nerd who can't
relate to women
Davis was such an extreme version of
this and he delivered unintentionally
hilarious moments so frequently that I
would classify him as what the internet
calls a low cow low cow is old 4chan
lingo it means a person who's
unintentionally eccentric or foolish
behavior can be milked for lulz milking
in this context can mean simply watching
a locales behavior and laughing at them
or it can mean making reaction videos
where you make fun of them or it can
mean actively trolling and provoking
them to get a response that you find
entertaining I described Harry's videos
about Davis or my old videos about the
golden one as law cow
content with a political angle it was
essentially an argument from ridicule an
argument from cringe with the aim of
convincing people don't embarrass
yourself like these ding-dongs but also
don't just speak for myself Here I am at
the end of the day an entertainer and I
wanted people to laugh there doesn't
need to be a political agenda behind
milking raw cows in fact usually there
isn't the purest example of a locale I
can think of is actually someone from
way before the internet namely Florence
Foster Jenkins Jenkins or Lady Florence
as she likes to be called was an
American soprano who attracted a cult
following in New York City during the
1920s 30s and 40s due to her being such
a terrible singer that people went to
her concerts essentially for the lolz
she was described as the world's worst
opera singer no one before or since has
succeeded in liberating themselves quite
so completely from the shackles of
musical notation behold this [ __ ]
camp Queen but we have no choice but to
Stan here's a short clip of one of the
few recordings she made cringe she was
essentially the Tommy Wiseau the William
Mahone of her age apparently she was
oblivious to her own incompetence until
1944 when she was 76 years old and she
booked Carnegie Hall for a concert to
which newspaper critics showed up the
next morning the New York Sun reported
much of her singing was hopelessly
lacking any semblance of pitch but the
further a note was from its proper
elevation the more the audience laughed
and applauded and five days later she
had a heart attack and died I find
something very touching about this story
I mean I'd probably be laughing as much
as anyone if I were at Carnegie Hall
that night but I feel so much
compassionate cringe for Lady Florence
it kind of makes you appreciate the kind
cruelty of Simon Cowell at least he
tries to stop these people before things
get out of hand
I think it's normal to have mixed
feelings about a little cow like yes
this is hilarious but on the other hand
does not a low-cal bleed on some level
we know it's wrong to entertain
ourselves this way
but on the other hand other people's
pain is incredibly entertaining there's
a good bug about this called the joy of
pain
schadenfreude ah in the dark side of
human nature by Richard Smith
schadenfreude ax is of course the
pleasure we take in other people's
misery in Smith argues that we
experience it because psychologically we
gain something when other people lose
for constantly evaluating our own worth
by comparing ourselves to other people
so we get a reassuring self-esteem boost
a pleasant feeling of superiority from
comparing ourselves to people beneath us
especially if were kind of insecure to
begin with maybe I'm not perfect but at
least I'm not this law cow and we also
get a boost when people who are socially
above us whom we Envy get brought down a
peg James Charles is canceled party lol
oh wow I think schadenfreude up
basically accounts for just a huge
percentage of the things that happen on
youtube.com Smith uses the word humility
menteur this type of media like reality
TV shows designed to produce spectacular
moments of embarrassment YouTube is
basically a big reality TV show or some
kind of carnival sideshow I mean take a
look around you
we have Eugenia Cooney a youtuber who at
the time I'm making this video remains
apparently in total denial about her
eating disorder and continues to make
videos modeling skimpy clothes for
millions of Gawker's we have wings of
redemption a bad-tempered gamer who for
a long time was essentially confined by
poverty obesity and depression to
streaming video games all day to an
audience of trolls that enjoyed
tormenting him we have Onision
a habitual alleged abuser of women and
teenage girls who earlier this year
essentially performed his own mental
breakdown on YouTube after patreon
banned him for dogs again accuser
I love kombucha this idea was it to give
hundreds of pathological narcissists
access to video equipment what kind of
sick social experiment are we living it
and the viewers are no better than the
performers every one of you blood
they're Stephenville yours makes me sick
oh you people love nothing more than to
watch one of us poor helpless egomaniacs
completely lose our minds live on camera
is this what you want huh you wanna know
Wow
you know as a creator you have to be
aware that you're a circus performer and
the crowd may in fact be more
entertained if you fall from the trapeze
and get used by the Tigers online media
today is full of lady Florence's anti
celebrities with anti fans now to be
clear I don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with indulging now and
then in a little bit of light
contaminant cringing at davis oriini or
bad American Idol auditions seems pretty
harmless but it can be taken too far and
there's no better case study of taking
it too far than the cult following of
one Christine Weston Chandler if you
don't know what's coming you might want
to strop engorge cuz this is coconuts
it's bananas it's a full fruit salad God
how do I even begin to explain this
well Christine Weston Chandler more
commonly known on the Internet as
Christian is the victim of what is quite
possibly the longest-running and most
obsessive internet trolling saga of all
time she's the low cow of low cows
hello everybody's just Christine
Chandler coming to you live from home
once again Chandler is an autistic trans
woman and yes I will be calling her by
she/her pronouns which I paused to
explain because I don't think I've ever
seen anyone actually take her transition
seriously most people seem to regard it
as simply another absurd symptom of her
hilarious mental condition in fact a
bunch of trans people will probably get
real salty with me for making trans
people's look bad by including Christian
in our o very prestigious and exclusive
club oh please transsexualism is a
deviant sexual identity sweaty this is
not the Princeton alumni Yacht Society
God how did [ __ ] get so snobbish
look is Christian really trans I don't
know
and I don't care if Christian wants to
be a woman
I for one support her journey but it
doesn't matter the relevant thing about
Christian is not Christian
it's the fact that for the last 13 years
nearly every aspect of her life has been
obsessively archived online by thousands
of new years known as Chris Torian
Chandler first acquired this anti fandom
several Internet centuries ago back in
2007 when a 4chan took notice of her
comic book series sonichu they
childishly drawn hybrid with Sonic and
Pikachu the comic is sent in quick Phil
CWC being Christians initials the
protagonist is a self-insert who
references Chandler's real-life quote
love quest to find a quote boyfriend
free girl which apparently involved
posting bizarre attraction science
around her Community College for this
storage makes sense you have to keep in
mind the Chandler identified and
presented as male until 2015 so these
trolls saw her as like the ultimate
autistic in sell lamb Charlotte just to
give you a feel for this person
here's Christine in 2018 holding up the
iconic pre-transition portrait with the
sonichu medallions here's the bedroom
she lived in and here she is in recent
years giving us a full BroNYCon eleganza
pegasisters snubbed basically she's the
entire cringe topia subreddit condensed
into a single person so fortunes erode
radiant on this [ __ ] because of course
they did and they began tormenting her
by creating pornographic parodies of
sonichu posting candid photos of her etc
Chandler reacted to the trolls which of
course encouraged some more and the
harassment escalated and escalated they
hacked her accounts or tricked her into
giving out passwords they posted all her
emails online these showed up in person
and photographed her house they called
her parents
posing as friends psychiatrists
journalists employers in order to
extract as much information about her as
possible and of course they contacted
Chandler herself which was very
rewarding for sure
because she has no filter and was very
naive and trusting so she was very
willing to divulge or easily manipulated
into divulging mortifying information
about herself sexual psychological
scatological there's not really any
limits or boundaries to this for all the
information they gathered the trolls
created a wiki called the quickie
devoted to the obsessive compiling of
all Christian data it includes a
detailed diagram of her bedroom entire
articles about all members of her
immediate and extended family pages of
psychiatric records she was tricked into
sending them and that's only the
beginning in their more grandiose moods
the Cris torian's have speculated that
Christian is the most documented life in
all human history comparing their social
experiment to The Truman Show it's a
level of obsession that surpasses the
wildest excesses of Stan culture it's a
gaze into the abyss that does not blink
some trolls have also sent taunting
letters and packages or on one occasion
sex workers to the Chandler household
two female trolls actually went on
real-life dates with Christian of course
secretly wearing wires to record their
conversations others pretended to be her
Internet girlfriends so they could
solicit and post nudes and masturbation
videos these things must be archived
don't you understand
Christian must be documented the
absolute low point came when some trolls
encouraged a thirteen-year-old boy to
pose as a 19 year old girl and have
phone sex with Christian and recorded in
other words they groomed a child to
deceive an autistic person into
performing sex acts for their
entertainment now to contemporary Chris
torian's this sort of sadistic
interference and Christine's life is
frowned upon not so much because it's
immoral so much as because it's
considered a bit tacky
a bit attention-seeking no to the
sophisticated Chris Torian feat real
pleasure in all this is supposed to lie
and quietly spectating savoring the fine
notes of cringe now I take it I don't
even need to comment on the morality of
all this the real question to me is why
why do thousands of people have a morbid
obsession with Christine Chandler and
yes it is an obsession just to give you
a sense of a single individuals personal
investment in this the youtuber Gino
Samuel one of very few Chris torian's
with the audacity to show his face has
been working for more than two years to
produce an eventual 100 episode
documentary series about the life of
Christian Gino has completed 36 episodes
so far and each episode is around 40
minutes long meaning he's already
produced around 24 hours of video about
the life of what is essentially a random
stranger I think this phenomenon
deserves its own name I'll call it
morbid cringe defined as an obsessive
and addictive contemptuous fascination
with a particular person or group why
does morbid cringe happen well I've
spent some time poring over Chris
torian's conversations with each other
and I've even interrogated a couple of
them and this is what I've found the
first thing they'll tell you is that
they just think it's funny and
entertaining that Christine's strange
life and mind simply appeals to their
morbid curiosity and I'm sure that's
true but a lot of things are funny and
entertaining and morbidly interesting
why fixate on this particular person
well for a lot of them it's a
reassurance that there's someone out
there worse than them maybe they're
nerdy loners with no social skills but
at least this defenseless punching bag
called Christian is here for them to
assert their superiority over it's
pretty much common knowledge that a lot
of Chris torian's including some of the
most vocal haters are autistic
themselves and a frequent justification
given for trolling Chris
is that she's giving autistics a bad
name in recent years there has also been
a small contingent of transgender trolls
who are likewise prone to say he's not a
real transgender like me and he's making
us all look bad oh yeah because people
who troll Christian you guys look
amazing
it's common for trolls to offer
rationalizations like this about why
trolling Chandler is justified righteous
even because at the end of the day
trolls are people too and a lot of them
actually do have a guilty conscience
about this which they suppress by
insisting that Christian is a horrible
person
who deserves to be tormented but trolls
who protests too much about the evils of
Christian and therefore reveal the
access of their emotional investment in
this are known in the community as a
logs a log is the name of a troll who
attracted the ire of other trolls by
ranting about Christians crimes
comparing her to Hitler and generally
betraying a pathological hate obsession
among the trolls this kind of behavior
is considered an embarrassment to all of
them because they want to feel like
they're just cruelly and casually toying
with this person you know just for
laughs not a big deal this is all
perfectly healthy and normal and fine
it's fine but a log gave the lie to that
illusion because it was obvious that his
Christian obsession wasn't healthy or
normal or fine so the other trolls
turned on a log and they made him into
Christian 2.0 and they uncovered his
autism in his furry porn collection and
his cringy erotic fan fiction so why
would someone as similar to Christian as
a log obsessively hate on her well
there's two explanations one is troll
shielding that is a log may have
performative Lea despised Christian and
spearheaded the trolling efforts in
order to protect himself from being
targeted by trolls the idea is that you
can protect yourself from the mob by
waving your pitchfork the hardest
obviously this did not work the other
explanation is that a log saw himself
reflected in Christian and sort of
projected his own shame and
self-contempt onto her a log hated
Christian because he saw part of himself
in her and the other trolls hated a log
because they saw a part of themselves in
him to quote Margaret Plus who covered
this story for New York magazine a few
years ago I think it might be a logs all
the way down people form morbid cringe
obsessions with Christian because to
them she's a symbol of something they
hate about themselves something they're
ashamed of maybe it's being on the
autism spectrum or being a socially
awkward recluse maybe it's being
unemployed and living with their parents
or an adulthood fixation on children's
cartoons or embarrassing sexual
proclivities or all of the above this is
how scapegoating works right you repress
your uncomfortable feelings of shame and
insecurity and self-loathing and you
displace them on to someone else usually
someone you can feel superior to then
you blame and persecute the scapegoat
transforming your painful shame and
self-loathing and to pleasant judgmental
self-righteousness it's pretty safe to
assume that a large percentage
of Chris torian's and trolls are some
kind of social outcasts much like
Christian so bonding together over their
shared contempt for Christian is a way
of processing the shame and anxiety of
social rejection and exclusion and I
think for a lot of people even normal
people who aren't part of a bizarre
internet stalker community contemptuous
cringing helps us cope with our own
shame and insecurities anyway it's time
to stop this tedious empathizing with
other people and find a way to make this
all about me
[Music]
meow-meow would you like to meet my
quarantine boyfriend would you like to
meet my boyfriend's boyfriend that's
right honey I'm giving you food Joshi
realness nah he's gonna stay right here
is a grim reminder of the things that
you have seen actually I identify as a
trap
it's very thought I guess that's not
really cringe if I'm trying to be cringe
cringes failed seriousness in my last
video I talked about how ashamed I am of
being a transgender lesbian cringe shame
at the end of that video I talked about
how I sense that my shame is related to
the contemptuous cringe I feel for a lot
of other trans lesbians particularly
those of the HEC and straight beasts on
yah yah cat girl variety but I confess
to periodically sinking into these
morbid guilty binges of cringing at
embarrassing trans lesbians I want to
return to that thought and kind of
psychoanalyze myself as a kind of
first-person case study of a morbid
crinch obsession so cat girl trans girls
are okay I can't believe I'm about to
explain this they're trans women usually
attracted to women who express their
identity online through cloying neoteny
otaku memory and my conscious reason for
cringing at them is that I see these
Japanese cartoon car girls as a kind of
visual baby-talk and infantilized an
unrealistic representation of femininity
and womanhood that's designed to
titillate nerdy boys so in trans women
identify with it I cringe like no you
can't become an anime girl Lily [ __ ]
your dreams now look I don't want to get
sidetracked with a discussion of whether
my opinions about cat girls are fair or
correct so don't listen to what I'm
saying about cat girl
listen to what I'm feeling about cat
girls listen to the contempt beneath my
words because even if everything I'm
saying is true
cat girls are being cringe online is a
situation so inconsequential that any
amount of emotional energy spent on it
is too much so why do I have this cringe
fixation well according to the a log
theory of morbid cringing we form
obsessive and addictive contempt for
people who have traits in common with us
people who make us uncomfortable because
we see something of ourselves and then
so do I have traits in common with the
Cowgirls well we're both trans women
we're both attracted to women
I do like anime but I don't like the
anime they like okay I like good anime
that has you know mature
three-dimensional female characters look
I'm a real transgender okay I'm not like
you it's also not lost on me that this
is like the seventh time on this channel
I've dressed as a cowgirl to make fun of
them I have posted cringe you should all
be laughing at me right now
yawn yawn yawn yawn yawn yawn yeah so I
do think there's some truth to the idea
that I'm a logging these cat girls I
also think is a group representation
aspect to this like I am afraid that
other people will cringe at a group that
includes me trans lesbians because of
how these cat girls are acting so let's
make another distinction between
in-group cringe and out group cringe and
group cringe is when you cringe at
someone who belongs to the same group
identity as you for example your family
your romantic partnership your ethnicity
or your country particularly if they're
embarrassing themselves in front of
outsiders to the group think about how
embarrassed a teenager gets if her mom
does something cringy in front of her
friends or think about how embarrassed
liberal Americans get when we talk to
foreigners about Donald Trump being our
president or think about these phrases
she makes me embarrassed to be a
youtuber they're making trans people
look bad he's giving autistics a bad
name when we crunches someone who
belongs to our identity group we don't
just feel vicarious and bear
we feel embarrassment because they're
disgraceful behavior makes us look bad
too so in group cringe is actually a
kind of self cringe because you're
cringing at your membership in an
embarrassing group nothing has ever
triggered this kind of end group
embarrassment more from me than a cringe
video there went viral last year in
which a masculine trans woman throws a
tantrum over being misgendered in a
Gamestop excuse me it's ma'am it is
ma'am this video is excruciating for me
to watch the paradoxical absurdity of
trying to brutishly intimidate people
and to seeing you as a woman mmm
Twitter's gonna come for me over this
and say Natalie hates trans lemonade
don't pass but passing is really not
what this is about
it's aggressive intimidating hyper
masculine behavior from a trans woman
accompanied by apparently total delusion
about how she's presenting it's really
not that clear Gorge and that's what
makes this video classic cringe right
the incongruity between her thinking
that she's serving woman while bellowing
like a drill sergeant by the way what
I'm doing right now this is cringe
reaction content I don't really do that
on this channel but I'm dipping my toe
in just as see how it feels
and it feels good like intoxicatingly
good I can see how you could get
addicted to this I'm imagining myself
right now surrounded by six people and I
am leading the righteous mob as we point
and laugh at some delusional
manly dumptruck I am a real transgender
a true transgender a good transgender
father find the approves of me this
would be the unconscious archetypal
father jot that down in my progress
notes please doctor okay so why does
this feel so good well let me talk you
through my feelings when I watch that
gamestop video for the first few seconds
I do feel vicarious embarrassment for
her I can't even relate because in the
first couple months of my transition
there was an occasion where I was in a
lengthy customer service interaction
where the guy at the desk
was calling me sir the entire time and
there's something very humiliating about
trying to present female like wearing a
dress and makeup and yet being called
sir it's a quintessential mismatch
between self concept and the way other
people are seeing you and the memory of
it is painful to me but what I cling to
is that while I may have looked like a
man at least I didn't act like a man I
didn't threaten to take anyone outside
and show them a sir in fact I was too
ashamed even to correct the guy so as
the GameStop video progresses my
sympathy runs out fast and instead of
compassionate cringe
I feel group embarrassment for trans
women including myself yet I feel
contempt toward this individual for
making us all look bad I also feel a
kind of morbid fascination rooted in
fear what if I masked illusional as that
trans woman I don't look and sounds like
that do i I feel like I have to do a
sanity check I start scrutinizing myself
in the mirror listening to recordings of
my voice just to make sure and that fear
motivates me to distance myself from
that person in the video
I don't feel compassion for her cuz that
would mean putting myself in her size 16
shoes and I don't want to do that
because I'm horrified and repulsed by
the thought that i'ma like her in some
way so I want to push away and contempt
as a way of emotionally distancing
myself and if I express that contempt by
publicly shaming and condemning her that
I'm also socially distancing myself
accidental kovat jokes oops guess it's
uh contagious
having many people who are stigmatized
or who have been humiliated long for the
experience of being unnormal surrounded
by fellow normals judging and
humiliating of freak and if you take a
look around trans YouTube a lot of the
biggest creators in the platform have
channels basically devoted to exactly
this type of cringe reaction humility
mantilla tuber Calvin Guerra is a trans
guy who's best known for what are
essentially cringe reaction videos
mostly aimed at people he deems trans
trenders that is people who claim to be
trans but who aren't real transgenders
like Calvin he's especially bothered by
Gurley a fab trans and non-binary
teenagers or by anyone who blurs the
line between lesbian and trans masculine
identities sometimes he'll do a
long-form reaction to a specific person
who grinds his gears so this person is
an asexual non-binary transgender
lesbian who uses he's a it Dawn's
pronouns according to my calculations
you are a transgender and other times
he'll basically just laugh at cringy
trans tik-tok teens he has a couple
justifications for making these videos
one is that he's actually helping the
people he's cringing at because of at
render transitions then they'll get
dysphoria and have to D transition but I
have to wonder does humiliating or
laughing at people really help them
figure out whether they're trans or not
his other justification is that trans
trenders are giving real trans people a
bad name they're the reason people are
transphobic this is why they hate us
it's because of the trenders well I love
that idea of a true scum free isn't that
just as much as wonderful true
discomfort but it's not though I mean
transphobia existed long before there
are people you could plausibly describe
as trans trenders so trans trenders
aren't the reason society hates trans
people Calvin they're the reason you
hate trans people right or at least the
trans community and I feel like what
you're doing is you're projecting that
feeling on justice
idea large and you're saying oh this is
the reason people are transphobic and to
be fair I get that it's not just a
projection like back in 2016
the SJW cringe era it was sis people
mocking trans people with all these
tropes attack helicopter two genders 76
genders special snowflakes but now
they're used by trans people trying to
distance themselves trying to get Oh
eyes the most laughed at people in the
community under the label of
transgenders and Calvin there may be
some truth to what you're saying about
their being confused teenagers who think
they're trans when they're not I mean I
wouldn't know I'm a near dead woman in
the twilight of my life and I don't hang
out with teenagers but even if it is
true Calvin your fixation on it seems
disproportionate to me like you return
to this topic to cringe again and again
and again and again and again and again
it's like you're picking out a wound it
feels to me like a morbid cringe
obsession and I guess I think I
recognize part of myself in you this
could be me projecting of course but I
wonder if the way you feel about girly
Sparkle gender a fabs
is similar to the way I feel about otaku
trans bein catgirls
and it might be worth considering that I
don't cringe at the sparkle genders the
way you do I mean I'm with you on
wondering what a he's a Z er gender flux
lesbian Demi boi is but unlike you
Calvin I just don't have a morbid
current obsession with feminine a fab
trans people they can identify as
however many genders they want for all I
care I may not always understand it but
I support their journey I guess it
doesn't bother me because I'm not
worried that anyone will judge me
because of how they bathe I don't feel
in Group cringe I was a different story
if I'm reading a general lesbian
subreddit and I see a comment like
pre-transition trans lesbian here I wish
I had titties girl dick Yaya get the
[ __ ] out of here Billy you're giving
real trans lesbians a bad name this is
why they hate us see now I have strong
feelings now I'm in group cringing and
intellectually I do think my feelings
are correct to some extent like I don't
think a general lesbian community is the
appropriate forum for a trans woman
who's effectively still living as a
to take the mic and whine about wanting
titties or rhapsodize about girl dick
but I'm also aware that I feel this
strongly about this because of my own
dysphoria and my own shame and honestly
my own self living like I can't even
talk just as women on dating apps
because I feel like a fake woman
imposing myself on real women that's
where my head is on so where does this
free transition trans lesbian get the
audacity you know it makes me feel in
group cringe about an identity trans
lesbianism which for me is already a
pain point of insecurity and
embarrassment and shame so Calvin maybe
and they can I could just be projecting
but maybe that's kind of like how you
feel about these trenders when you make
these videos condemning them as not
really trans aren't you essentially
exiling them from the in-group so you no
longer feel the pain of in-group cringe
or perhaps calvin guerra which you're
really trying to destroy is the Trender
within
and again I could be full of [ __ ] here
at the end of the day this is
psychoanalysis of a youtuber I haven't
met so feel free to tell me if I'm full
of [ __ ] Calvin but still I guess I
invite you to consider whether producing
transgender humility mint is actually
helping anything or whether it's really
just an addictive way to scratch some
kind of emotional itch
alright I've said my piece about Calvin
who's about Vanessa we meet again Gorge
and once again I wearing some kind of
embarrassing anime hairpiece vanessa is
a trans woman who is the second most
popular political transit to birth at
least that's what I wrote in the script
when I had more subscribers than her and
was fully prepared to be a cut about it
but since then she has in fact surpassed
me once again good for her vanessa
started out as basically a cringe
reaction channel back when sjw cringe
was fashionable she crash at a wide
variety of sjw's but the most consistent
theme was trans trenders and crazy
activists are giving real trans people a
bad name they're making us look bad this
is why people hate us so we can now
recognize because a standard in-group
cringe fixation but Vanessa focused in
particular on his strident SJW type
trans woman called Wylie Dennis and
Vanessa made several reaction videos to
her where she made a point of
misgendering royally and dismissing her
as a fake transgender who hadn't
transitioned and clearly had no
intention to you know if you went on
estrogen your sex drive wouldn't be so
high and you wouldn't be guilt tripping
people into having sex with you just
saying but then why they made a video
revealing that she'd been hormone
therapy for a year and was about to
undergo facial feminization surgery this
prompted Vanessa to make an apology
video where she not only apologized sir
Miley and acknowledged her transition
but she actually went beyond the script
of a generic oopsie-doopsie YouTube
video and to opened up about having
experienced herself the cruelty she
directed at Riley and I'm someone who
has had my transition picked apart on
line there have been reddit threads and
4chan guys with hundreds of comments on
it of people trying to prove that I'm
not chance because I haven't done this
or that or you know digging up my old
pictures and so the thought that this
entire time I've done that exact same
thing to someone else and pushed that
off on someone else [ __ ] with me and
I'm [ __ ] sorry Vanessa I actually
managed for one fleeting moment to make
a connection between her own pass her
and trauma and the pain she did selected
on another person which is kind of a
once-in-a-lifetime event on a website
where the performers are remorseless
Psychopaths who wouldn't muddy their
shoes to save a drowning child and the
viewers are cold-blooded sadists who
consume human misery like a glutton
gorging himself at a particularly
sumptuous buffet you know this whole
thing has really taught me a lesson that
I should really try to stick to ideas
opinions
policy however this lesson would not
last
Vanessa kept doing SJW cringe content
well past the point that had become
passé making a video with big red in the
thumbnail as recently as 2019 I admit I
thought she was fading into irrelevance
but once again I underestimated Vanessa
in july 2019 her channel rocketed to a
new level of success when she released a
video titled exposing jessica Yaniv
trans predator in this video Vanessa
sounds the alarm about a trans woman or
rather she believes a man posing as a
trans woman called Jessica
yaaayyy who the [ __ ] is Jessica Yaniv
well as far as I can tell everything
Vanessa says about you Nev is true yaniv
attempted to use a Canadian Human Rights
Tribunal to close down several beauty
salons that had refused to walk her
hairy balls
after she approached them about it in an
awkward and creepy way she has a long
history of sending extremely
inappropriate messages to underage girls
and she attempted to host a topless pool
party
for unchaperoned children basically
Yaniv is someone who appropriates the
language of transgender acceptance and
equality to cloak predatory behavior
toward minors admire ii don Yaniv by the
way is not that she's a cunning
manipulator but that this is someone who
is mentally not playing with a full deck
after the success of her initial video
Vanessa made a few more videos about
Yaniv rebranding herself as a kind of
transsexual Chris Hansen exposing
transgender predators wherever she could
find them and at first I was honestly
kind of loving this for Vanessa at least
now she's finally picking on someone who
deserves it but the more I think about
it the more hesitations I have one is
that Vanessa framed the Yaniv story and
the lack of attention given to it by
other trans public figures as an
indictment of trans activists who
Vanessa thinks should spend more time
sounding the alarm about transgender
proudly and I'm willing to admit there's
probably a valid point in there
somewhere like some trans people really
are so paranoid about transphobes
framing all of us as dangerous perverts
that they basically look the other way
and refuse to acknowledge the small but
real subset of trans people who are in
fact dangerous perverts but Blair you
talk about the Yaniv situation like it's
urgent breaking news like Yaniv should
rightfully be a household name but for
the stubborn silence of trans activists
but why why should everyone be focused
on Jessica yaniv there's more than a
hundred thousand sexual assaults
reported to American law enforcement
every year the literal president of
America is a bit of a sexual predator
himself why fixate on this one
particular Canadian creep I guess you
could argue that since Yaniv is a trans
identified predator a tip we as real
trans people have a responsibility to be
the ones who lead the charge to stop her
or at least it would be good optics for
us to do that and again I think there's
maybe some true
to that like initially the LGBT website
pink news straightforwardly reported in
Eve's claims of discrimination which is
pretty embarrassing and not great optics
but I don't think that constantly
broadcasting updates about the
transgender what is really the best
optics for us either
why did you Anessa make this video in
the first place is it simply because she
cares deeply about the well-being of
children and she thought making a video
exposing Jessica Yaniv is the best way
to protect them I mean yeah I'm sure she
cares a little bit about the children
but it's still a YouTube video and you
have to ask is the primary intention
here really to stop a predator or is it
to manufacture a sleazy entertainment
spectacle shortly after her first Geneva
video was published
Vanessa hosted a live stream on her
channel titled heated debate with
Jessica Yaniv trans predator this got 2
million views is this what you do with
someone you've just accused of
pedophilia you host a live event
debating the pedophile on your YouTube
channel what's to debate I don't need to
be scared of my own house that I'm gonna
get [ __ ] to talk to the legal in
Canada just that but I think that was
like you will that a moment for you then
of course you sell t-shirts featuring
the meme that resulted from your YouTube
pedophile debate I mean that makes sense
if you're gonna catch a predator you
gotta sell pedophile debate merch and of
course you gotta follow the pedophiles
makeup tutorial you know for the
children now I hate to be overly
critical but when I look at this I don't
see a high-minded activist working to
protect children and trans people's
image I see a tabloid entertainer who's
discovered a way to monetize milking
lols from a mentally defective pervert
and I have to say Blair as
connoisseur of trash myself I'm very
entertained by all of this
following a sexual predators makeup
tutorial that's genius I wish I'd
thought of that but just be honest this
isn't activism this isn't justice
it's a low-cal cult it's like one of
maari's transsexuals took over the show
and I love that for her I love that for
her but Blair I can't help but notice
you're still hitting all the same beats
your videos have always hit attention
everyone there is a bad transgender in
our midst the bad transgender is not a
real transgender like me it's very
important that we all gather around to
condemn this bad transgender who is not
a real transgender and Blair will give
you this you are getting better at
choosing your targets the transvestite
monster is a stock character in our
culture and Jessica Yaniv is good
casting for the part she's a trans folks
boogeyman
come to life and I certainly am NOT
shedding any tears for her but you'll
have to excuse me if I don't take this
seriously as anything more than a
smarter version of the same in-group
cringe humility meant you've always made
and by the way you may want to check in
on your understudy Rose of dawn Rosa
Fatone is another conservative trans
woman youtuber who produces a series
called trans stupid hi everyone and
welcome to another edition of trans fat
the show where I take a look at the
wonderful world of lgbtqia+ plus plus
knees because stupidity is
intersectional transgender more like
trans [ __ ] more like trans gay trans
I'm literally tightest realize I'm
literally trans gay roses channel is
allegedly about the excesses of trans
ideology and activism which in theory I
do think is a perspective worth
including in the conversation but in
practice well let's just say Rose has
produced a 30 minute documentary about
why Christian
is not a real transgender there is a bad
transgender in our midst the bad
transgender is not a real transgender
like me I'm getting pretty tired of this
and here's her transition advice to
trans women just beginning their journey
you probably have this image in your
head that you know you're going to be
this really cute looking trans men that
you like effectively you're going to be
this seal like look at this it isn't a
seal adorable you're so cute but but the
truth is you're probably not looking
like this seal right now are you know
you're probably more like this big bull
seal barging your way into women's
bathroom saying this is a woman's body
now you might never reach the cute seal
phase in fact very few of us to how it's
a lot like Blair White Rose no do not
simpler Vanessa it only encourages her
she's also made no less than 20 videos
about Jessica Yaniv which seems like
kind of a lot Gorge
would I be wrong to say I'm getting a
little bit of a morbid cringe addiction
vibe in these videos Rose Chronicles
young Eve's numerous crimes and
wrongdoings but she also cannot resist
making it very clear how disgusted she
is with young Eve's appearance the irony
being that this kind of tweets came from
someone who you can smell just by
looking at a picture of them I bring
this up again not because I have any
interest at all in white knighting for
you Nev I do not support her journey as
far as I'm concerned she can eat [ __ ]
and maybe she does I wouldn't be
surprised no my point is that part of
the catharsis that rose and Vanessa
seemed to derive from making this kind
of content comes from contrasting
themselves as good presentable real
trans people with the hideousness of the
wretched fake trans dump truck a classic
Vanessa thumbnail is divided into two
halves on one half vanessa cooking fish
[ __ ] always with her lip gloss in the
livestream and in the other half of the
thumbnail for contrast the tragic dump
truck in a maladjusted wig and I'm
allowed to say dump truck because before
I transitioned I was one of Vanessa's
dump trucks I was one of hashtag her
dock truck look I happen to possess a
little thing you probably haven't heard
of it called inner beauty that's right
sweetie my pancreas unlockable meanwhile
Rose who refers to represent herself
with this cartoon okay
straight up refers to an divas the tubby
Troon and the Titanic trainer of Canada
a particular Titanic Runner of Canada
that's light sonic trauma of Canada
trainer and trone being pejoratives for
transgender that I associate with 4chan
or I'm guessing Rose has spent a lot of
time
as for the emphatic revulsion toward
your Neves fatness well I'm guessing
that must be another important part of
stopping a predator right it seems
almost taboo to condemn people for how
rough they look when I think that that
tough love in a way is needed because I
look at what I looked like when I first
translations
Jesus Christ I wish my friends had said
something like I looked bad like I was
overweight I had poor taste in clothes
like I was never wearing stupid dresses
the ranking was mostly t-shirt for jeans
he probably more like it'd be worse you
barging the way to women's bathroom
saying this is a woman's body now
[Music]
Rose are you okay no you're not okay
none of us are okay no trans woman
remotely in the public eye is in any way
okay and look I don't want to take the
psychoanalysis too far because I don't
know from watching YouTube videos what's
going on in someone's head but I can try
to make intelligent inferences and I
think it's pretty revealing that this is
how Rose introduces the topic of just
like I you Nev think well one of the
biggest characters in the whole [ __ ]
world at the moment which is Jessica you
Neve Rose Gorge yesica and Eve is not
one of any moment this is not a world
historical figure at the end of the day
this is a more or less random civilian
sex fiend off the streets of Vancouver
BC the only reason anyone has heard of
her at all is that Vanessa decided to go
fool to catch a predator and turn this
grimy reprobate into a minor anti
celebrity she is not one of the most
important characters in the world but it
sounds like what she is Rose is one of
the most important characters in your
brain this is distorted thinking it's
like a log comparing Christian to Hitler
you're so deep in the morbid crunch
obsession that you've lost perspective
and I'm sure you have what seemed to you
like perfectly logical reasons while
you're devoting so much attention to
this and I know videos about Yaniv get a
lot of views so I'm sure that's a factor
too but Rose I also know a morbid cringe
obsession when I see one
and I know that being a visible trans
woman on the Internet is more difficult
than most people can imagine and I know
that pretty much every trans person is
bullied or ashamed or humiliated at some
point in our lives and I know how good
it can feel to take all the horrible
things transphobes and bullies and
turf's have said about us and repeat
them verbatim about some big fat fake
dangerous delusional disgusting male
fetishists oh it feels good to be the
turf for once it feels good to be the
judge rather than the judge because when
you point the finger at someone else
you're also pointing away from yourself
and it's not lost on me
that in conservative circles queer
people are often treated like suspected
sex criminals by default so there's
safety and being the one who spearheads
that think of the children
type moral crusade and when you expose a
trans predator you get that feeling of
safety plus the relief of having someone
in particular to blame for the shame and
stigma we all feel jessica Yaniv is the
reason people hate us but that's just
not true it's a simple answer to a
complicated problem
it's scapegoating when I look at the
Univ of session on trans YouTube I see a
community trying to cope with stigma and
hoping that destroying a scapegoat will
bring relief it's basically a blood
sacrifice it's not rational it feels
good for a moment but it's an addiction
it won't ever erase the stigma and the
shame and genève is simply the latest
and most deserving in a long line of bad
transgenders who aren't real
transgenders and are giving us a bad
name and are the reason people hate us
and must be condemned and destroyed but
when you Nev is finally gone when you
got her sent to prison or whatever your
goal is you're just gonna find a new
scapegoat to take her place and the
shame cycle continues the humiliation
and bullying we've experienced is
internalizes shame when we project that
shame onto scapegoats and onto each
other it becomes cringing and contempt
and we voice that contempt by shaming
other people which starts a new cycle so
you can keep finding new scapegoats new
punching bags new shame dumps new law
cows and you can end up like one of the
people who's been archiving Christian
for 13 years but that will never really
heal us God how do I get out of this
video I'm trying to have a serious
conversation dressed as some sort of a
cowgirl degenerate cringe shame I
don't look at me you know I love wearing
florals in front of flowers thank you
yes I suppose it is groundbreaking all
right children let's review our notes on
cringe the word cringe really describes
two different emotions either
embarrassment or contempt you can feel
either one for yourself or for someone
else when you're barest for someone else
we call that vicarious embarrassment and
that can mean cringing with someone who
has embarrassed themselves which I've
argued is excluded in the internet usage
of the word cringe or it can be
embarrassment for someone who isn't
embarrassed themselves in which case we
say we're cringing at them now if
someone who's part of your in-group
is embarrassing themselves and by proxy
embarrassing the in-group that includes
you you feel in-group cringe which can
involve both vicarious embarrassment and
a kind of self cringe and on the
contempt side contempt for someone who
shares traits in common with you
particularly if their traits you have
contempt for in yourself can develop
into morbid cringe which is that
obsession with a locale that addiction
to contemptuous gazing at a dark mirror
in which you see reflected everything
you hate about yourself or about your
in-group now I want to end this video by
reflecting on whether cringe is good or
bad
healthy / harmful and I do think that in
some situations crunch is good
embarrassment serves a social purpose
it helps us interact smoothly with each
other by telling us what not to do and
empathizing with other people's
embarrassing stories can be cathartic it
can make you feel closer to other people
more alike less alone I also think a
moderate amount of self cringe is very
healthy it shows you're self-aware and
you care at least a little bit what
other people think you know I've met
people who never cringe it themselves
and let's just say they're not my kind
of people
they're narcissists who think super
highly of themselves regardless of how
they're actually coming across but I
think partly out of fear of ending up
like one of those people
I've overcompensated and I cringe too
much both at myself and at other people
it's a habit that's kind of making me
hate myself and it's making me unfairly
contemptuous towards others and when I
take a look around the inner
like I've done in this video I find that
I'm not alone in this situation and it's
not cute
so how do we cringe less well the cliche
solution is self-love which our culture
places a lot of value on self love and
self esteem you know I don't care what
haters and losers say I'm a bad [ __ ] I
look like a supermodel
I am a genius we're encouraged to hype
ourselves up in this way but it doesn't
work because it's not realistic you
don't look like a supermodel and you're
not a genius and when you realize that
you fall from one extreme to the other
of what Chris Fleming calls the
self-esteem Tower of Terror the or
himself love to self hate but self-hate
is also a distortion recently I was
listening to a David Foster Wallace
interview yeah I know
cringe and he attacked me mercilessly
and unprovoked there's that there's a
lot of narcissism insult hatred how dare
you notice that I'm in this photo and I
don't like it but it's true time spent
cringing out yourself is still time
spent obsessing over yourself and it's
hard not to because humans are animals
so our perspective is egocentric by
nature but we can still learn to
appreciate that the world is bigger than
us I mean I've heard rumours in that
book we started with cringe-worthy
Melissa doll advocates not self-love or
self hate but what she calls self
indifference
she says self indifference is the relief
of realizing that you are simply not
that big a deal so yeah I was pretty
crunchy in the past and I'm still pretty
cringing now but you know what everyone
else is pretty crunchy too and the world
is probably going to burn down in 50
years anyway so I don't know if I would
call this good news but if it's any
consolation nothing matters
nothing matters nothing matters nothing
matters nothing matters nothing matters
nothing matters
[Music]